if you spread the water across many many
seeds you don't have as much water for
one seed I want to know why why is it
done that way is there a better way to
do it is there another way to do it we
don't have to wait for somebody to
greenlight our projects we can create
our own intersection man it's like wild
horses in my head sometimes there's so
many ideas and they're all over each
other all of the power that you have and
all the strengths that you have and all
the ideas that you have are in are born
in your uniqueness sometimes you have to
be hidden sometimes people are not
supposed to recognize you there's no
chair thrown or anything like that but
but I will set it straight if
something's wrong you know what the
thing is man I'm a student of life and
every day something in my life is is
reminding me of something that I could
write about everything that happens to
you can work for your good if you let it
we were poor but we were busy I'll know
why poor people was so busy he's an
American actor TV producer filmmaker and
songwriter specializing in the Gospels
on room he wrote and produced many stage
plays in the 90s and early 2000s here in
a hundred and thirty million dollars in
2011 and Forbes named him the highest
earning man in entertainment he's Tyler
Perry and here are his top ten rules for
success my only idea my only focus was
to do my one play and I knew if I could
get that to work everything else would
come to pass there's so many people who
go in so many directions they this week
they're doing this and next week they're
doing that and next week they're doing
this and next week they're going to be
in real estate the next week they're
going to open the salon it those those
kind of people are all over the place
and I usually try to get them to focus
focus on one thing one area put all of
your energy into watering one area if
you spread the water across many many
seeds you don't have as much water for
one seed so focus on one thing make it
your priority and stick with it no
matter what no matter how many people
told me no no matter how many people
lied to me no matter how many times I
put the show up and nobody came that I
remembered when I did my very first show
I worked my butt off and saved $12,000
tax returns donation are black money I
saved
work hard safe to myself ready to the
14th Street Playhouse put that show up
thought that 1,200 people would come
over a weekend and 30 showed up and I
knew everyone up but I didn't stop that
didn't deter me that was in 1992-93
same thing happened I 94 95 96 97 up
until 1998 same devastation nobody
showing up in the audience I'm still in
one show a year working with different
promoters trying to get the show up and
nobody showed up but I didn't stop and
my my what I say to you now looking at
me now Here I am a human being there's
no difference between my humaneness and
your eminence the only thing is if
you're trying to get there
you cannot stop believing in any way no
matter what anybody says no matter what
anybody tells you you have to know it
beyond knowing it and it is a it is a
feeling when something is for you this
is our news for me when something's for
you there's a feeling that it's deep
down inside of you that will not allow
you to let it go you have it will it
will keep you going when you can't even
keep yourself going that's why the
mantra here at the typewriter Studios is
your place where even dreams believe
because there comes a time in your life
where you work to stress then you try to
get there and you couldn't on your own
but you have a dream and that dream has
to take on the belief for you because
you can't do it by yourself so what I
would tell you is this
don't stop narrow your focus to one idea
one and make it work
that will give birth to all the others
one of them of the most difficult things
for me when I first got to Hollywood was
trying to understand how it's done I met
I've never been the person that walked
in the room and said and they say stand
here move here sit move go and do that
and do that and do this and do this and
you'll get here I've been the person
that goes that move here go here do that
and I go okay well why are we doing this
I want to know why why is it done that
way
is there a better way to do it is there
another way to do it and if you tell me
this is the way it's been done all of
our lives for a whole that makes no
sense to me I've always challenged it
I'm not I'm not a rebel but I've
challenged the thinking and I do that a
lot in my own studio now too for people
who come in with this complete set of
rules of this is how it's done well does
that feel right to you so it's about
what what feels right and I'm hoping
that I can convey that I wanted to use
my gift to not only make us laugh but to
make us think I wanted to use film to
not only entertain but to let us know we
don't have to wait for somebody to
greenlight our projects we can create
our own intersections I wanted to use my
television show to not only make us
laugh but to show us that we don't just
have to act in the sitcom we can own the
show and the network I wanted to use
giving in philanthropy to show us giving
and philanthropy to show us that we
don't have to be at the end of the line
waiting for a handout we can be at the
front giving the hand up
and I wanted to own a studio to show us
that we don't have to wait for somebody
to give us 40 acres and a mule we can
buy our own
so I am grateful and I wanted to use my
childhood to let each and everybody know
that no matter you can be born into a
whole lot of a nightmare
but you can God can usher you into a
dream I love to work there's a script I
have in my head now it's been in there
for about two years that I really have
to sit down to write because it's almost
like giving birth because sometimes the
ideas are men it's like wild horses in
my head sometimes there's so many ideas
and they're all over each other I have
to take this idea and let it be born
because if not it'll push everything
else back what I would say to people who
want to become means don't become me
become the best you you can be because
what I found there early on is that all
of the power that you have and all the
strengths that you have and all the
ideas that you have are in are born in
your uniqueness and what makes you
unique and this may sound really says
but it's just really true what makes you
unique is what makes you special and if
you don't if you spend your whole life
trying to conform trying to be whatever
somebody else that thinks you should be
or fit into a mold or fit into a system
and you doe down your specialness then
you're dulling down all of your ability
to change the world so I think that it's
very very important that people have an
opportunity to be the best of themselves
that they can be I want to talk about
something that happened recently with a
friend of mine he called me up he said
you know you're contagious I said well
I'm not contagious he said you know I've
spent some time working with you now I'm
going to start my own business I said
great man that's great he said well when
you see it you know don't it's nothing
there's nothing impressive and I was
explaining to him never never despised
small beginnings the Bible says that
never disturb never despised small
beginnings there are things that
happened that can happen out of the
smallest little start that can change
the world I also he was telling me how
frustrated he was because nobody notices
him or nobody sees him and nobody would
give him a break and I explained to him
about in my own life how sometimes
sometimes people are out trying they're
pushing they're getting cars they're
trying to be seen they're doing all of
this stuff sometimes God will hide you
and let me tell you how I know that in
my own life
I was under the radar for a very very
long time and for the most part I still
AM believe it in that I really am your I
was kept from a lot of things a lot of
kept from being exposed to a lot of
business ideas and business situations
and business thoughts or how things were
run and by me being kept away from that
it allowed me to not be tainted by it so
sometimes you have to be hidden
sometimes people are not supposed to
recognize you sometimes people are not
supposed to invite you to the table you
can't be angry about it you need to
accept it and find out why why am I
being hidden because I tell you now had
I went the route that I wanted to go
what would have happened is I would
ended up in Hollywood and did the deals
that everybody else had done and there
would be nothing different nothing
spectacular about the blessings that
I've received it would just be an
average story but because I was hidden
because I didn't know how it went
because I didn't know how things were
supposed to go in film and television
that ignorance allowed me to carve my
own way I know this may be difficult for
some people to understand but but hear
me clearly when I say this because I was
hidden because nobody knew what was
going on with the success that I was
having on the plays it was all
underground when I got there I was able
to make deals that are unprecedented
they didn't think there was anything to
it because they didn't know who I was
completely underestimated the great
thing about being hidden is that you can
be underestimated and when you're hidden
and you're underestimated you're able to
do some things that will not only change
your path your life but the lives of
millions of people the ones around you
your children your family it will uplift
and change everybody
and everything so what I say to you is
if you're struggling and you're fighting
to be seen sometimes you're supposed to
be hidden it's not your time to be seen
yet stay the course learn what you can
walk in the path that you're supposed to
at this time and at the right time God
will reveal you your talents and
everything you've done to the world
in the meantime prepare I like working
with people who like to have fun because
I like to have fun I don't think
everything has to be serious
duty now no man in the kitchen when I
said that bang this should be fun the
place should be fun the movies should be
fun it should be a light atmosphere it
should be a place where you come in you
want to stay all day because got to be
there 1214 hours so if I'm gonna be
around the people we may as well try and
have a good time don't come here take
everything else crap what'd I tell you
lord help is that the key to my car you
sob and my phone you know
so in order to have that I have to make
it light I don't let that fool you cuz
there's here and there are some moments
where there's no chair throwing or
anything like that but but I will set it
straight if something's wrong I have no
problems with switching it up and that's
what's so great about professionals they
know it's how far we can play in clown
around cos when we hit that stage even
though we're having fun they know it's
very serious to me
hey I Terry up Tom Paradis Rodney
Mitchell where do you get your source of
inspiration for new movie themes like
those in temptation you know what the
thing is man I'm a student of life and
every day something in my life is is
reminding me of something that I could
write about like this I met somebody
that I thought was really really special
we never we never crossed any lines but
she was amazing she was married again
hear me clearly we never crossed any
lines but what happens is when I when I
wrote this movie I started thinking
about what if what if what if and that's
how I write these stories because I just
keep asking myself what if what if what
if what if so it starts with the nucleus
of just me meeting some woman that I was
very very attracted to the thought she
was amazing and knowing that I probably
if I had pushed the envelope I probably
could have so I was tempted she was
tempted but I have a respect for the
union of marriage and I also believe you
reap what you sow so I would never do
something that I feel would come back to
me one day I always only want to put out
good things because I only want good
things to come back to me but in saying
that that's where this story came from
the first initial nucleus of it and then
I just added all the other stuff what if
we had given in what would have happened
and what would have this and what would
have that and that's where this came
from
I found out in life that everything that
happens to you can work for your good if
you let it no matter how bad no matter
how traumatic you know for me my
turnaround came when I forgave my father
for everything that he did and I
realized after doing that that
everything that had happened had brought
me to this position where I am now and
has allowed me to be able to write these
stories and then develop these
characters because had I not been
through those situations I wouldn't have
the experience to be able to do that
what can you tell other people not
everybody can afford therapy can go out
and say you know what I've just got it
within myself we all have it right but
how do you get that person on the street
or that person who feels like these are
the four walls that I am just stuck in
get him out the thing about it is what
that's what I think my shows all the
plays that I've done in the and the
movies have been so successful is
because a lot of people can't afford
therapy I never went to therapy but what
these what might what my characters and
everything they speak to it a give
advice in situations on trying to put a
mirror in front of people to say is this
me it provokes thought it makes people
want to offer it offers change or the
possibility of hope and I think that
what's important for people who are
really really going through and don't
know how it's just once it for me was
faith it's a lot of Prayer I totally
believe in God and and people may
believe in other things but for me it
was God faith in prayer and and that for
me had there not been Church and to help
me get through those things I don't know
what I was let me tell you how I met mr.
Butler I just started doing a high
school and in order for me to get to
high school I had to walk through the
drug dealers literally step over the
horse and the drug addicts walked
through a graveyard then the next block
passed gang members and then go through
the projects and then come to a six-lane
intersection and it was always busy but
just beyond that was the school well one
day as I'm approaching this intersection
I hear this voice saying will someone
help me cross he was in a suit he had a
cooler in a hand and a folded lawn chair
in one hand and his cane in the other
will someone help me cross he said
people kept annoy him walking past him
with their busy lives we were poor but
we were busy I don't know why poor
people was so busy
I said I'll help you in my 13 year old
changing voice he said well thank you
son may I have your shoulder I wish I
had time to talk about giving your
shoulder to somebody I said yes sir
he said don't trick me now I said no sir
I won't we crossed the street I asked
him where he was going he told me that
he was going to to my school to sell
praline candies to the kids so help them
to the school and he said thank you and
he told me that God would bless me for
my kindness he and I became friends we
took that walk every day I came out of
school one afternoon and there he was
sitting outside in that lawn chair
selling praline candies 25 cents and I
saw one of the kids tried to buy candy
right
and they gave mr. Butler a dollar and
they told him it was five dollar bill I
stepped in and I said mr. Butler this is
a scam needless to say I had a lot of
enemies at that school but it didn't
matter I was glad to do it
you see mr. Butler was one of the first
men in my life to see me and what made
it all the more special is that he was
blind he was a point of light one
morning I was late meeting him and as I
walked up to the in exciting
intersection I could see mr. Butler
standing there not saying a word so I
took tup behind him and I said I said
I'm not gonna say anything I'm just
gonna wait to see what happens he said I
know you're there son I said yes sir I
am
I said I didn't hear you saying will
someone help me cross he said no I was
listening for you I said you were he
said yes sometimes in life son when you
pray and you said all you can say all
you have to do is stand and wait and
listen what a point of light he was
there are many people in this world that
are wanting waiting saying asking
begging hoping will someone help me
cross we all have the power to be a
point of light thank you and God bless
you
appreciate it so much thank you so much
for watching we made this video because
bodacious 40 asked us to if you have
another entrepreneur your mind you want
us to profile leave it in the comments
below we'd also love to know which of
Tyler Perry's top 10 rules meant the
most to you leaving in the comments will
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching and continue to believe and
we'll see you soon